as I've gotten older man the other thing
that is really getting me now for
whatever reason and I do feel like such
an old man when this happens is I'm on
the lurka for people scamming
[Music]
but you know the biggest scam going for
me you know the biggest scam going is
I'm sure we've all been in a grocery
store recently with one cashier and 40
people in line or some and what do
they always saying
you can use the self-checkout
for your convenience
is that convenient for me
is it convenient for me to leave my job
my house and do your job is that
convenient let me tell you what's really
convenient when I go to the grocery
store and I put my food on the food
right
thank you and I hear this
would you like to meet this ever back no
that's cool that's it
that's it you know it's not convenient
me itself check out trying to figure out
how to bring up bell peppers that is not
convenient go find yourself check out I
would never eat another fruit or
vegetable again in my life and by the
way now if you buy some expensive now
they won't let you check out now you
don't trust me eat my here's the deal yo
if I sell check out I'm stealing all
these two things that's it
if I'm gonna do the work you're gonna
pay me that's it
[Music]
[Applause]
bell peppers four zero eight eight
[Music]
yo how many times have you had to stream
that over a loud speaker
foreign
[Applause]
just checking his knowledge just
checking his knowledge
hey hey bell pepper guy hey where do you
work man I do home health right now
[Music]
he just wants all of us to know he
doesn't work in the AGP anymore
that's fine where did you work where
yeah how
Albertsons twice what happened in
between the first Albertsons in the
second album
s yeah yeah but I I can't imagine
anybody going well I guess I'll go back
to Albertsons
like I just want to know where it went
from Albertsons
to be like I wish I could be working in
Albertsons right now
I think we're all curious how many you
had to suck to get back to Albertsons
the insult doesn't count if you whisper
it like a so I'm saying
okay oh you're gay okay yeah yeah
[Applause]
well then there's a definite number yeah
yeah now I really want to know
hey
[Music]
[Applause]